there's a fear that robots will take our
jobs I just um I took a ride I was in
San Francisco to go riding way more
Vehicles than autonomous vehicle and uh
I've done it several times they're
they're doing incredible work over there
uh but
uh people flicked it off around the car
so I mean that's a long story of what
the psychology of that is it could be
maybe big Tech or what I I don't know
exactly what they're flicking off yeah
but there is an element of like these
robots are taking our jobs or or
irreversibly transforming Society such
that it will have economic impact and
the little guy will be uh would lose a
lot would lose their well-being is there
something to be said about
um
the fear that robots will take our jobs
you know at every
um significant technological
transformation uh there's been fear of
you know an automation anxiety yes that
it's going to have a broader impact than
than we expected
and there there will be uh
you know jobs will change
um sometime in the future we're going to
look back at people who manually
unloaded these boxes from trailers and
we're going to say why did we ever do
that manually but there's a lot of
people who are doing that job today
that it could be impacted
um but I think the reality is as I said
before we're going to build the
Technologies those very same people can
operate it and so I think there's a
pathway to upskilling and operating just
like look we used to farm with hand
tools and now we farm with machines and
nobody has really regretted that
transformation
and I think the same can be said for a
lot of manual labor that we're doing
today
and on top of that you know look we're
we're entering a new world where where
demographics are going to have a strong
impact on economic growth
and the you know the advanced uh the
first world is losing population quickly
um in Europe
they're worried about hiring enough
people just to keep the logistics supply
chain going
and you know part of this is the
response to covid and everybody's sort
of thinking back
what they really want to do with their
life but these jobs are getting harder
and harder to fill and I just I'm
hearing that over and over again
so I think frankly this is the right
technology at the right time
um where we're gonna need some of this
work to be done and we're going to want
tools to enhance that productivity and
the scary impact I think again uh GPT
comes to the rescue in terms of being
much more terrifying
um the scary impact of basically so I
I'm a I guess a software person inside a
program a lot and the fact that people
like me can be easily replaced
uh by gbt
that's going to have a
well a lot you know anyone who deals
with texts and writing a draft proposal
might be easily done with a chat GPT now
Consultants
journalists yeah
um everybody is sweating but on the
other hand you also want it to be right
and they don't know how to make it right
yet it but it might make a good starting
point for you to iterate boy do I have
to talk to you about modern journalism
that's another conversation altogether
but yes uh more right than the average
uh uh the the mean journalist yes